figaro lie bonjour à tous on en direct
ce matin pour continuer de parler bien
évidemment de ce qui se passe en russie
on va parler aujourd'hui des sanctions
économiques qui vise la qui utilisent la
russie donc que d'autres parlent de ce
qui se passe en ukraine excusez moi je
suis avec florentin collomb grand
reporter juriste spécialiste économie
europe bonjour avec vous a parlé de tout
et de tout et sanctions votre article de
retrouver dans le journal du jour je
vais vous le montrer aussi sur
sur ce live il est ici guère de en
ukraine des sanctions provoque un choc
financier majeur à moscou florentin on
peut commencer par parler de ce qu a
déclaré bruno le maire ce matin le but
de la france et de l'europe c'est
d'asphyxier l'économie russe c'est ce
qu'il a dit oui il a même dit que
l'objectif est l effondrement de
l'économie russe c'était des mots très
forts d'un ministre de l'économie et des
finances est asphyxié c'est le bon terme
parce que c'est exactement la méthode
choisie c'est à dire que par rapport à
d'autres types de sanctions économiques
dans des conflits précédents en iran ou
pas voilà la corée du nord par exemple
on ne vise pas un embargo commercial
c'est la méthode la plus classique là on
utilise le nerf de la guerre qui ai
l'argent donc la finance et ses des
sanctions contre la banque centrale
russe contre les banques russes privées
du système de paiement international
swift qui vise à assécher l'économie
russe de toutes rentrées financières de
l'extérieur donc d'isoler la russie
complètement en la privant de moyens
financiers est-ce qu'on peut rappeler ce
que c'est cette selle cette fameuse
mesure swift face au fameux réseau swift
ça a été présenté comme le dernier
recours finalement il a été activé très
vite à quoi ça sert aiguille est ce que
c'est c'est remarquable la façon dont
les choses sont allées vite puisque
vendredi encore à paris les ministres
des finances européens étaient réunis et
swift été évoquée par bruno le maire
comme l'armé nucléaire aujourd'hui cette
arme de dissuasion massive elle et elle
est utilisée elle est mise en oeuvre
alors le réseau swift c'est un réseau de
paiement c'est à rennes une sorte de
messagerie sécurisée pour les banques
existe depuis 50 ans c'est une société
belge en fait qui permet de simplifier
les transactions internationales entre
les banques c'est à dire si je veux
virez moi de l'argent à moscou je le dis
à ma banque qui l envoie un message à la
banque à la banque de france qui le
renvoie à son tour un message à la
banque centrale de russie qui va le
répercuter à la banque de la personne à
qui j'ai envie d'envoyer de l'argent
donc on coupe complètement ce système de
paiement ça veut pas dire qu'on ne peut
plus faire de transaction pourra
toujours mais il n'y aura plus le
système hi media enfin relativement
rapide swift puisque c'est pas tout à
fait immédiat mais c'est rapide et donc
il faudra passer par des envois de
lettres des deux jumelles de fax
documents etc pour faire ces
transactions de plus il ya un embargo un
embargo total sur les transaction avec
la banque centrale russe ça veut dire
que la banque centrale russe a développé
en prévision notamment de ce type de
conflit un trésor de guerre de 630
milliards de dollars donc ce sont des
réserves en or et en devises étrangères
qui sont à la fois détenues en partie
dans des coffres à moscou mais aussi
dans les banques centrales des autres
pays et ses réserves la sont gelés donc
la banque centrale russe en est privée
c'est à peu près la moitié de ses
réserves donc c'est un trésor de guerre
qui a été accumulée ces dernières années
il a vraiment fait fait croître de façon
très très prémédité
vladimir poutine et du coup il est privé
de la moitié de ce trésor de guerre
c'est ce qui a provoqué l'effondrement
du rouble hier donc le rouble a chuté de
30% à l'ouverture des marchés 2
des change
des devises hier ça s'est redressé un
petit peu entre temps mais le cet effet
symbolise l'isolément enfin la
dévaluation totale de 2,7 de cette
monnaie russe donc les rues sont en
d'autres moyens pour essayer de défendre
leur monnaie mais ce sont des démarches
de manière très limitée comme la hausse
des taux d'intérêt qui a été décidé hier
par la banque centrale donc elle a
relevé son taux directeur qui était à
neuf et demi jusqu'à 20% donc le taux du
loyer de l'argent en russie est de 20%
aujourd'hui c'est une façon de compenser
la baisse du rouble mais ça ne suffit
pas à restaurer la stabilité monétaire
et financière je voulais montrer
justement ça alors ça c'est sûr google
télé c'est laisser la chute du rouble
dont tu parlais justement c'est vrai
c'est clairement une chute massive tout
d'un coup en fait oui très brutal hier
30 % à l'ouverture pour apprécier
remonter un petit peu mais c'est une
dévaluation très forte de la monnaie
russe il faut plus de 100 $ pour avoir
un rouble aujourd'hui il faut plus de
100 groupes pardon pour un dollar et du
coup ça affecte les économies des russes
surtout que le rouge alors là je suis
montré sur la sur une perte de temps
plus longue tombe depuis alors je ne
sais plus froid que c'est 2005 tout en
bas ici à ses 2500 c'est c'est cette
monnaie est en chute quand même depuis
un moment oui oui la monnaie mais là
c'est les sanctions financières on a vu
le l'effet immédiat des sanctions
c'est à 24 heures sur ces sur les
économies des rues c'est aussi le seul
sur le les pannes des entreprises sur
l'ensemble de l'économie du pays est ce
que c'est la première fois que des
mesures aussi aussi fortes sont prises à
l'encontre d'un pays comme ça de façon
coordonnée oui voilà on est en
territoire inconnu parce que des mesures
isolées de ce type ont déjà été prises
mais pas par une coque avec une
coordination tel internationale aussi
rapide et mise en oeuvre avec autant
d'efficacité
donc on est vraiment en territoire
inconnu parce que on ne sait pas en
réalité pour l'instant on voit bien
l'objectif qu'avait qu'on vient de
décrire mais on ne sait pas exactement
quelles vont être les effets et quelles
vont être les marges de manoeuvre qui
reste à la russie pour essayer de
défendre son économie on a en interne
dans le jet qui nous demande pour le
bonjour tout le monde est-ce que les
sanctions contre l'iran comprenez ces
mêmes mesures ou est-ce que c'était
moins violent non c'était un embargo
commercial après il ya des mesures
proprement américaine qui interdisent
aux banques de commercer avec l'iran
d'ailleurs des banques françaises en ont
subi les les conséquences mais des
mesures comme ça n'ont jamais été prises
de sortir complètement un pays du
système de la communauté financière
internationale donc ça ne s'est jamais
vu comme ça justement qu'est-ce qui
pouvait bloquer d'autres ont parlé au
début de l'allemagne qui seraient
réticents à faire sortir la russie lit
du système swift pour quelles raisons
ben pour sa part en raison de sa
dépendance à l'énergie russe
les sanctions là elles sont encore
discuté aujourd'hui à bruxelles le
détail du nombre de banques et de lui le
nom de chaque banque qui qui va être
impacté directement et victimes de ces
mesures ça a été assez difficile pour
les européens de se mettre d'accord pour
pour dégainer ses sanctions qui sont
massives et dont on va subir aussi des
répercussions nous on en parlera après
donc l'allemagne était réticente et
l'italie aussi parce qu'elles sont très
dépendante des approvisionnements en
hydrocarbures depuis la russie la
hongrie aussi peut-être pour des raisons
politiques également mais finalement ces
réticences ont été vaincus très
rapidement en
24-48 heures au cours du week end
là la solidarité occidentale a pris le
pas sur les intérêts individuels cela
dit les européens préserve leurs
intérêts quand même puisque dans ces
mesures certaines banques vendent en
être isolé et on aura le détail
probablement dans la journée ou demain
permettant de continuer à commander du
gaz et du pétrole en russie donc les
européens en fait c'est désintérêt un
peu bien compris dans dans les sanctions
c'est à dire que les européens préserve
ouvre laisse ouvert le robinet des
approvisionnements en gaz et en pétrole
et en même temps ils laissent ouvert
dans l'autre sens un robinet
devises pour pour moscou donc moscou
peut encore compter
dans dans l'état actuel des choses sur
20 à 25 milliards de rentrées nettes de
devises par mois donc la russie n'est
pas complètement asphyxié justement
parce que si on avait voulu là se fixer
on couperait complètement les échanges
de dib d'hydrocarbures comme de tous les
biens et ça poserait justement des
problèmes pour pour l'énergie en europe
puisque l'europe est quand même encore
très dépendante de la russie oui
l'europe est dépendante à 40% du gaz
russe
25% du pétrole produit en russie va en
europe donc en effet on a vraiment
besoin de cette énergie donc les
européens là dans l'espèce de sursaut
stratégique qui est en train de se
produire en marge de ce conflit sont en
train d'essayer de chercher des parades
et des alternatives mais ça va assez
loin puisque en allemagne par exemple
qui a décidé de bannir le nucléaire
on est en train de éventuellement
revenir temporairement sur cette mesure
de mettre fin totalement nucléaire pour
ne pas rester dépendant de livraison de
charbon par exemple de la russie donc ça
remet en cause des des décisions qui
avaient été prises
l'allemagne en particulier a fait un
revirement à 180 degrés à bien des
égards sur les livraisons d'armes sur
ses sanctions sur sa dépendance aussi
commerciales avec la russie donc cette
crise faire ça offre un nouveau
paradigme quelque part que ça va tout
changer delà de la façon dont
l'allemagne et même beaucoup d'allemands
de l'europe vous voyez les choses oui
mais cd c'était des mots d'ordre qui
était un petit peu abstrait et un peu
vain jusqu'à présent emmanuel macron
d'ailleurs n'arrêtait pas de parler de
souveraineté d'autonomie stratégique de
l'europe s'était il évoquait sa sous les
aspects à la fois économique et
militaire les européens discutaient
depuis longtemps d'une espèce de
boussole stratégiques c'est-à-dire de
définir quels sont leurs intérêts
stratégiques et militaires
mais tout ça reste est à l'état presque
virtuel enfin c'est une discussion
presque
sur
discussions en fait abstraite or là on
est confronté à la réalité des choses et
des choix et c'est vraiment ce qui est
en train de se passer c'est en train
c'est ce qu'on est en train de voir avec
l'allemagne sur revirement l'italie
aussi a fait un revirement la suisse qui
est sorti de sa neutralité pour
rejoindre tout le train de sanctions
pris par les occidentaux ça c'est
vraiment exceptionnel que la survie sort
de cette gravité bien sûr il ya eu
beaucoup de débats en suisse mais ils
ont mis quelques jours à le faire mais
mais mais la suisse est sortie de sa
neutralité pour prendre des sanctions
contre un état du fait de la situation
géopolitique aujourd'hui et ça veut dire
qu'ils désirent la russie comme un
agresseur dans cette histoire j'en
profite pour passer le bonjour à dld qui
viennent nous dire bonjour sur le site
du figaro vous n'hésitez pas bien sûr à
nous poser toutes vos questions on va
essayer d'y répondre le mieux possible
j'avais une autre question effectivement
sur cet article jeudi
l'idée c'est de provoquer un choc pour
la population en russie pour les russes
est ce que l'on sait ce que ça peut
produire pour l'instant oui alors les
répercussions pour la population sont
plus compliquées à percevoir et est ce
que l'idée est de provoquer un choc sur
la population je pense indirectement
c'est à dire que il ya probablement dans
l'idée des occidentaux
la volonté de retourner le peuple contre
vladimir poutine par l'économie en leur
faisant vivre une situation économique
difficile pour que le ceux qui
soutiennent vladimir poutine alors
réfléchissent sur sur ce thème
concrètement on a quand même vu
moi j'ai parlé avec des gens à moscou
hier il n'y a pas de réelle panique au
sens où les gens chercheraient à retirer
toutes leurs économies des banques etc
mais il ya une inquiétude très très vive
et on a vu des files d'attentes aux
guichets des banques depuis ce week-end
dans un premier temps c'était pour
essayer de retirer des devises mais ne
peuvent plus
maintenant les gens ce que les gens
cherchent à faire c'est m
un petit matelas de départ ni chez eux
de précaution donc ils ont peur que le
système bancaire finalement soient pas
réalisés et ils essayent de se mettre du
côté des moyens de vivre pendant
quelques semaines donc donc c'est quand
même très inquiétant ce matin les firmes
de cartes de crédit américaines
mastercard et visa ont décidé de couper
les banques russes de leur service donc
pour les russes qui ont des cartes de
crédit de ce type ça ils ne peuvent plus
accéder à l'argent donc donc c'est
réellement un sujet de préoccupation
même s'il n'y a pas eu de panique
bancaire en tout cas pour l'instant
après les effets vont être lent et
douloureux pour la population russe
comme pour toute l'économie russe c'est
à dire qu'on s'attend à une inflation
encore plus forte elle est déjà très
forte en russie mais elle pourrait
bondir delà de 10 % peut-être 15% parce
que le les coûts des matières apporter
vont être de plus en plus élevés la
russie importe beaucoup de bien de
consommation courante de biens
d'équipement et c'est même alimentaire
et puis et puis cette situation va
inévitablement on va plonger la russie
en récession donc
les entreprises les petites entreprises
vont avoir du mal à se financer vont
avoir du mal à accéder au crédit non
voix risque de voir une multiplication
des faillites sera un effet sur l'emploi
les particuliers eux aussi auront du mal
à accéder au crédit peut-être les
grandes entreprises seront en partie
épargnés parce que la direction
le gouvernement a cherché à
rééquilibrer ses relations commerciales
donc elle compte sur d'autres
partenaires les émirats par exemple
abonnés ne se sont pas dans les
sanctions et continuent à échanger avec
la russie la chine sur tout mais on
verra quelle est l'attitude de la chine
dans dans cette situation elle est
loin d'avoir apporté un soutien total à
moscou dans cette affaire et on verra
elle est un peu ambigu sur la façon dont
elle va soutenir moscou mais
moscou compte beaucoup sur la chine pour
diversifier ses sources
d'approvisionnement en devises oui c'est
une pauvre c'est une c'est quelque chose
qui est assez floue comme coupables ont
une très bonne question de dates erin
alors c'est plutôt sur les sur les sur
le réseau européen est ce que à ce stade
l'effet boomerang sur les pays qu'ils
prennent des sanctions et sur l'économie
mondiale de manière générale et il
évalué à sa juste mesure c'est-à-dire en
fait on prend des mesures contre la
russie mais effectivement est-ce que ça
va pas des mesures contre nous au final
oui oui c'est inévitable on va subir les
répercussions de ces sanctions et de ce
conflit commercial puisque c'est un
partenaire important mineurs pour des
pays comme la france mais quand même
important sur certaines aux
approvisionnements stratégiques
donc
les évaluations des répercussions sont
encore un peu timide et pas très
précises elles sont faites un peu sur un
coin de table
on pense que la croissance en europe par
exemple pourrait peut-être réduit de 0,5
point par rapport à ce qui était prévu
cette année d'ailleurs la banque
centrale européenne la semaine prochaine
va établir des nouvelles prévisions
économiques
donc il est assez inévitable que la
croissance sera revu à la baisse une
nouvelle fois parce qu'elle avait déjà
été à cause de du vague rendu valeur au
micro
donc il y aura un effet indiscutable les
principaux effets ils sont liés à
l'énergie une fois encore puisque les
coûts de l'énergie vont augmenter
le pétrole est à plus de 100 dollars
déjà ce matin il pourrait monter encore
donc et le gaz est également ça se fait
aussi donc les prix de l'électricité et
de l'énergie en général vont augmenter
ça va faire augmenter l'inflation qui
était déjà très hautain plus de 5% dans
la zone euro en janvier on saura demain
le chiffre pour février et puis le pique
semblait très proche mais finalement il
sera peut-être plus lointains et et
l'inflation va pouvoir peut-être
continuer à augmenter dans le courant de
cette année donc ça va réduire le
pouvoir d'achat est pesé en effet sur
sur l'investissement sur la consommation
donc sur la croissance il ya aussi la
question d'aider des matières premières
de agricole aussi qui joue le blé par
exemple le blé le blé a fortement
augmenté on est très dépendant du grès
du blé russe et ukrainien d'ailleurs
il ya aussi des produits stratégiques
dans l'industrie certains métaux comme
le palladium le nickel dont on a besoin
dans les batteries dans le tome dans
l'industrie automobile et ses industries
étaient déjà freiné par des pénuries par
des goulets d'étranglement par des
problèmes logistiques
d'approvisionnement depuis toute la
crise sanitaire et on pensait qu'on
allait pouvoir en sortir dans le courant
de cette année que les choses allaient
se se calmer sur ce front et bien les
tensions avec la russie vont encore plus
compliqué les choses et ça aussi ça a un
effet inflationniste
on a des idées dans le couvent dans les
commentaires des filles en qui nous vaut
une question alors on n'aura pas la
réponse a bien évidemment mais les
sanctions contre la russie même efficace
peuvent-elles influencé l'opération
militaire en ukraine c'est tout l'enjeu
de ces sanctions quelques passes et
l'enjeu à la fois psychologiques
politique et économique c'est-à-dire de
priver la russie de ressources pour
financer son opération donc si si si
le conflit devait durer la russie se
trouverait face à un problème de
liquidité et de financement de son armée
parce qu'il va falloir remplacer tous
les véhicules les armements endommagés
et c'est donc oui c'est l'idée mais là
on se place dans la perspective d'une
guerre longue et d'une espèce de guerre
d'usure aussi avec ce front économique
qui vient puisqu'on ne répond pas
militairement l'occident pour aider
l'ukraine et bien on essaye de
contourner cet obstacle en asséchant le
financement de la russie y compris de
ses opérations militaires et forcément
c'est une méthode qui prend plus de
temps que des arnaqueurs or for web on a
une question en danger à une question
aussi sur les sur le sou les banques
russes est ce que les banques russes
peuvent finalement faire faillite à
cause de ces de ses nombreuses mesures
qui les touchent oui certaines banques
russes sont proches de la faillite
notamment la première d'entre elles à la
sberbank alors peut-être pas en russie
mais elle a des filiales en europe qui
elle la banque centrale européenne à
dire que l était en fort risque de faire
défaut donc de faire faillite parce que
elle va être asséchées deux
de ces deux transactions financières
donc oui des banques russes peuvent
faire faillite en effet on avait aussi
une question sur toutes les sanctions
qui touche en premier les citoyens le
régime aude en dernier l'idée s'est
sentie aussi c'est d'arriver à viser
directement vladimir poutine lavrov est
ce qu'on appelle les oligarques oui
c'est aussi alors il ya plusieurs
cercles dans les dents dans les
sanctions il ya un cercle très fort qui
vise à toucher a frappé très durement
les oligarques c'est à dire tout le
premier sac de vladimir poutine c'est à
dire tous les business men sur lesquels
ils se il s'appuie et on parle de
plusieurs centaines de personnes et
d'entreprises donc l'idée c'est de les
couper un peu du régime de poutine en
leur rendant la vie impossible sont des
gens qui sont par définition très riches
qui ont eu une vie à internationales qui
ont des résidences en france sur la côte
d'azur en suisse en angleterre à londres
qui ont des yachts qui ont des avions
des jets privés etc et on veut essayer
de les priver de tous ses moyens
de vie en fait de deux
ils risquent d'être assigné à résidence
là où ils sont ils risquent de se voir
saisi leur propriété la france a des
bruno le maire encore une fois à des
mots très durs sur la question en disant
qu'il avait mis tous les services de
bercy des douanes etc
sur la piste de tous les avoirs de ces
oligarques il parle de 400 à 500
personnes en france pour les saisir
directement c'est même pas les gelées
sait les saisir
donc si ces oligarques sont
assignés à résidence à moscou en russie
ne peuvent plus voyager ne peuvent plus
faire de business avec l'occident l'idée
c'est que il arrête de soutenir bladimir
comptines et on a vu que certains à voir
prendre leurs distances avec le régime
de poutine mais enfin ils prennent aussi
beaucoup de risques pour eux-mêmes s'il
rentre en résistance politique donc
c'est un aussi un outil de pression à
moyen et long terme c'est à dire
concrètement le gouvernement pour
gouvernement français pourrait récupérer
les villas par exemple des oligarques
russes sur la côte d'azur par exemple
comme il y en a on le récupère les
villas dans les semaines à venir oui
c'est l'idée en tout cas celle annonce
par le ministère de l'économie de 2 de
son intention après je pense qu'il faut
définir les modalités de ces saisies de
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on ce qu'on en fait
est-ce que c'est définitif ou pas
légalement mais en tout cas il a les
bases légales internationales pour
lancer ce type de mesures tu parlais
aussi des voyages des voix et être des
compagnies aériennes les compagnies
aériennes qui se rendent ce qui se
retrouve aussi dans ce jeu dans ce jeu
dans ce jeu de sanctions au final les
compagnies russes qui ne peuvent
quasiment plus voler ça fait partie
de cette stratégie d'isolement total
de la russie donc les compagnies russes
ne peuvent plus voler parce qu'elles ne
peuvent plus
survoler l'espace aérien européen
elles ne peuvent plus atterrir dans ces
pays
donc en effet
les résidents sont assignés à résidence
en face on ne peuvent plus voyager à
l'international pas d'aller en chine
peut-être ils peuvent aller dans dans
des pays amis mais pas venir en europe à
venir aux états unis
donc en effet pour les compagnies
aériennes russes c'est un problème c'est
aussi un problème pour les compagnies
occidentales il ya des compagnies comme
finnair par exemple en finlande qui subi
très fortement les répercussions de
cette no fly zone et puis même des
compagnies comme air france pour elle ne
peut plus voler ne peut plus aller à
moscou saint pétersbourg etc mais même
pour ses liaisons vers
l'asie vers le japon ont survolé la
sibérie donc elles doivent faire des
routes alternatives qui sont plus
longues plus cher plus compliqué donc
plusieurs vols ont été suspendus ces
derniers jours il va falloir s'adapter
donc c'est jamais bon pour le transport
aérien dans son ensemble de 2,2 de
décréter des zones où le sur veut dont
le survol est interdite donc là aussi
c'est décidé compagnie française fif
faire des foyers français c'est bien sûr
qu'il vaut et qui vaut qu'ils vont payer
le prix de ses entouré que par partir du
prix ouais effectivement on est une
question de yogi là aussi assez
tactique on va dire le rythme les
entourent c'est aussi pour pauline de le
faire basculer vers une fuite en avant
de faire une guerre totale comme et
comme il nous le dit mais ça on ne peut
pas le savoir encore pour l'instant
c'est le risque des sanctions mais le
l'alternative aurait été très dangereuse
de le laisser avancer en ukraine sans
réagir déjà qu'on ne réagit pas
militairement puisque l'ukraine n'est
pas membre de l'otan et on voulait pas
rentrer dans une ce camp était une
troisième guerre mondiale
c'est cette réaction au contraire a pris
de court c'est la coordination des
réactions occidentales et des mesures
prises a pris de court probablement
vladimir poutine et le gouvernement
russe
de toute façon on ne sait pas dans quel
état d'esprit et psychologique il est
mais il est dans une détermination
totale je ne sais pas mais très
dangereuse en tout cas
d'essayer d'arriver à ses fins après il
ya aussi la résidence la résistance
militaire des ukrainiens qui lui donne
du fil à retordre donc l'escaladent elle
n'est pas on peut pas dire que les
occidentaux et contribuer à une escalade
de la situation par ces sanctions
puisque personne n'a provoqué vladimir
poutine dans cette affaire on est une
question de moyens qui nous reparle du
risque de swift le risque de la russie
privé de swift et qu'elle s'allie à la
chine est de créer un système concurrent
pour lutter contre les saisies du dollar
c'est ce qu'elle essaye de faire déjà
depuis longtemps elle a beaucoup réduit
ses réserves de devises en dollars pour
rebasculer rééquilibrer avec un panier
d'autres devises dont le yuan chinois
et elle a aussi lancé son système de
paiement concurrents de swift si on peut
dire c'est balbutiant c'est beaucoup
plus petits c'est beaucoup moins
opérationnelle
ça concerne surtout des banques russes
et aujourd'hui elle essaye d'attirer de
demander à des pays amis dont la chine
ou le pakistan peut-être l'inde de
rejoindre ce système il faut voir si
cela va se faire de toute façon la
russie avec ses alliés seul mais enfin
ne pourra pas concurrencer le système de
paiement international swift qui
comprend onze mille banque est la
question à bordeaux si c'est laisser la
vision de la chine on en parlait un peu
tout à l'heure la chine n'est pas
clairement non plus un allié de la
russie actuellement non la chine
ap a condamné l' attaque en ukraine mais
elle ne la cautionne pas non plus donc
on va voir à moyen terme comment cette
relation va évoluer pour la chine
violer les frontières d'un autre état
n'est pas admissible donc il n'est pas
évident que la chine voit d'un très bon
oeil et au contraire ce qui se passe en
gaz avec l'ukraine
on a une question je pense qu'on en a
déjà parlé tout à l'heure mais on peut
peut-être leur dire à combien s'élève le
montant des réserves de change russes
détenus dans les banques étrangères par
led alors le total des réserves de
devises et d'or ces 630 milliards de
dollars et ça a beaucoup monté ces
dernières années et on estime que 40 à
50 % sont détenus dans les banques
étrangères donc sont aujourd'hui
indisponible pour la russie est gelée
dans les coffres des banques centrales
étrangères on à lui qu'il nous demande
pourquoi tout ils planifient de petits
bénéfices cela depuis un bon moment est
ce que en tout cas cet axe aux canettes
on peut dire qu'elle est planifié grâce
justement à cette réserve de change au
final ou au contraire il s'est donné les
moyens de ses opérations militaires en a
tiré les leçons des principales de deux
des principales crises et des
précédentes mesures de sanction il y en
a eu déjà à la fin des années 2000 puis
en 2014 lors de l'annexion de la crimée
donc la russie est aujourd'hui moins
vulnérables par rapport à cette période
d'un point de vue financier grâce à ses
réserves grâce à cette stratégie
financière et monétaire de doper
finalement son muscle financiers et ses
réserves
donc en fait oui il ya eu une montée en
puissance
de de la russie de la banque centrale
russe pour pouvoir faire face à des
sanctions qui était finalement attendu
et prévisible ya une question aussi
concernant le north stream 2 le fameux
pipeline qui devait donner du gaz à
l'allemagne sont là sa construction est
complètement à l'arrêt aujourd'hui alors
que c'est quelque chose de très
important pour l'allemagne quelques
parts oui oui c'était très important
mais très contestée aussi un même avant
l'invasion d'ukraine il y avait beaucoup
de pression en europe pour que
l'allemagne à être ce projet donc le
projet est aujourd'hui gelée
il ya quand même des approvisionnements
en gaz puisqu'il ya un hors stream 1 qui
permet aujourd'hui les livraisons de gaz
à l'allemagne et au reste de l'europe
mais c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
l'allemagne se retrouve face à des choix
stratégique très important en matière de
politique énergétique
et puis toute l'europe aussi on aille au
gui qui nous demandait sur la suggestion
de poutine catulle prévu ensuite on va
pas pouvoir lui répondu qu'on n'est pas
dans la tête de poutine on aimerait bien
savoir aussi mais effectivement on ne le
sait pas et une jolie qui rappelle que
si la suisse sorte de sa neutralité
depuis le traité de vienne de 1815 c'est
que la situation est très grave là en
effet c'est ce que le c'est le message
que la suisse a voulu faire passer en
disant que quand on voyait la carte des
interdictions survol du territoire de
l'europe dimanche soir oui elles ont été
annoncées dimanche soir par la
commission européenne il y avait un
petit cercle au milieu de l'europe
continentale c'était la suisse donc ça
n'aurait pas eu beaucoup d'effet puisque
les avions n'avaient pas arriver
uniquement d'après pc le suisse mais
enfin ça se voyait mais du coup la
suisse oui a décidé il ya eu des débats
hier au conseil fédéral
de rejoindre ces sanctions est en effet
c'est un
signe de la gravité de la situation et
de la façon pour la suisse de
reconnaître la gravité de cette
situation et de participer au concert
des nations alors n'hésitez pas à poser
votre dernière question on va bientôt
terminer ce direct la question vous le
voulez poser aussi c est ce qu on s'est
un peu où va pouvoir aller là l'économie
russe est ce qu'on sait si elle peut
résister à toutes ces sanctions et
combien de temps elle peut le faire on
sait pas combien de temps et on ne sait
pas exactement comment l'économie russe
a des atouts elle a des produits des
matières premières des métaux
stratégiques
elle elle est aussi le pib russe est
aussi soutenue largement par la
consommation intérieure donc elle ne
peut pas elle ne va pas s'effondrer du
jour au lendemain c'est pour ça que les
mots de bruno le maire sont peut-être un
petit peu fort on comprend l'intention
mais les faits ne va pas se produire du
jour au lendemain mais à la longue si la
l'économie russe entre en récession
cette année et le reste probablement
l'année prochaine on va constater une
érosion de la situation économique est
déjà pas très très bonne et ce sont les
russes qui vont en payer le prix merci
beaucoup florentin d'avoir été avec nous
ce matin pour décrypter toutes les
sanctions économiques n'hésitez pas à
continuer de suivre les directs du
figaro on vous tiendra informé bien sûr
vous avez donc le live sur le site du
figaro en temps réel vous avez donc cet
article de florentin colons guerre en
ukraine les sanctions propre des chocs
financiers majeurs à moscou et cet après
midi il y aura il y aura un grand débat
à l'assemblée nationale justement sur
cette guerre de la russie en ukraine du
coup je vous souhaite je vous dis à
bientôt sur figaro live et pour de
nouveaux lives